Así es jueves del segundo de los tres
días de la conferencia del agua de la
ONU hoy habló Francia y defendió varios
de los puntos que pueden ser los más
destacados de toda esta conferencia el
primero de ellos es que respaldó la idea
de Alemania de crear un enviado especial
de la ONU para el agua y afirmó que se
necesita Pues el informe síntesis del
ipcc revelado esta semana reitera una
vez más que los efectos de la crisis
climática no conocen fronteras por eso
Francia aprovechó el momento para hacer
un llamado a un trabajo
transfronterizo y coordinado de igual
manera habló Turquía y si bien no se
refirió a conflictos internacionales si
destacó su papel en la seguridad
alimentaria esto En relación con el
acuerdo de granos del que ha servido
como mediador entre Rusia y Ucrania
Aunque bien no se mencionó al agua que
es el protagonista por de esta Cumbre y
mañana viernes será el día decisivo
donde finalmente se conocerá si hay
propuestas específicas o no pues hasta
ahora no se conocen lo suficiente y es
Entonces cuando se sabrán los
compromisos voluntarios de la agenda de
acción por el agua mañana viernes día
clave entonces pero María Clara Mientras
tanto le pregunto Cuál es la postura de
los países latinoamericanos que han
expresado en esta Cumbre los países
latinoamericanos tienen un papel
preponderante pues es en esta región
donde están dos de las cuencas más
grandes del mundo Estas son las del río
Amazonas y la del plata por un lado en
el Amazonas han hablado indígenas que
vinieron desde Ecuador y desde Brasil no
han hablado aquí en la sede central de
la ONU sino que lo hicieron en The
nature Hub un pabellón Paralelo que
también está ligado a esta conferencia
del agua y defendieron su papel como
Guardianes del y como los primeros
Defensores del medio ambiente un rol que
también ha sido destacado durante las
plenarias y que los países ya comienzan
a reconocer por su parte Paraguay habló
como el presidente pro tempore del
comité intergubernamental coordinador de
la Cuenca del plata Que reúne a cinco
países Estos son Argentina Bolivia
Brasil Uruguay y Paraguay y se refirió a
la sequía que enfrentan varios de estos
países especialmente Argentina y Uruguay
que desde 2019 enfrentan una de las
peores sequías que han vivido en años y
que de hecho ya comenzaron a afectar su
producción agrícola al respecto Paraguay
planteó el trabajo cooperativo entre los
países como la posible solución y se
mostró ante la ONU como un ejemplo para
replicar el cuidado de los ríos que
atraviesan distintos países y es que dos
terceras partes de estos Ríos tras
fronterizos actualmente no cuentan con
ninguna seguridad y un dato para cerrar
Panamá podría ser el primer país
americano en unirse al convenio del agua
de la ONU un convenio que aplicó
originalmente para Europa Aunque por
ahora los trabajos todavía están en la
política interna